коко люстру вали довжиною 100 висимо
висотки українців по садівці
ці пропонують люстрації звивини не
близько тисячі чиновники
за оборону на обидві мото державні посади
до 2024 руку та 2 тувалу міністерстві
юстиції офіційно очищення відриваючи ж
сир і them all ряд карбування статуї на
влада так і заново жилося та провести
широкомасштабну люстрацію glyco сліди
ри 2 системи а полюстрово не про авто кл
з країни киш вище вся освоїлася іонів
та влади за крима про нинішній парламент
21 народний депутат Заходу, що забив
стіна до блоку та зміцнює падаючи пити diy
закону про люстрацію ще до десятка
чиновники серед януковича завищується
на високих постах поки що на вч і влади
провалу на люстрацію dash настановні
не прирікай опер очищення владика жити і
міні гирло особливо під від kitty там
Натомість успішним виявилося і
очищення влади видосі пов'язані з кгб так
вже повністю провали на так зла на мій
нова люстрація
agip асад був і покликала не чуючи 111
посадів тиф та гени змогли підтвердити
законність схуднення своїх стад kef а
сестри що хабар накипу корупціонерів у
uri дисп одягаються на інші то
підчищення запишемо коми про прилюдне ні
одна коронна декларація лише це деколи
таких людей не буду владних кабінетах та
можна було б вирито про успіх
ілюстрації до ж про динзі ініціатора
йогор соболів знайдуть арканії судді
очищення влади в Україні фактично
натрапила засудивши за встань ерік була
сильна наша одного служителя феміди
x голову вищого до іспанського суду
віктор знову когось за законом про
ілюстрацію та петляв та sudeki ух валі
вали на правому світ не рішення друк
євромайдану
а також течі та рішення з косово
європейський суд справлю ден і так їх
служителі феміди сотні, проте у строго
на висоті 2 десятки
проблема в тому ще суди вищі інстанції
став in a big своїх звіриних колег і до
допомагають їм по але вліво тасячи на фасадах
резервату цезар на nokola
і допомогти в новій нескладі судді могла
б 100 реформа
порти його поки що на спортивні